[Music]
and the crowd is on their feet I mean
he's from PG County yeah but Blackson is
on his back on the bench
well I said it wasn't gonna be easy
tonight I think this is a prime example
just that put in gaffer in the spin
cycle for Easy two
Sons will kind of work their way back in
by getting those high percentage shots
like they always do
Booker on the drive and delivers a
Booker boom he's more than just that
feathery soft jumper
[Music]
[Applause]
Ingram that's right Ingram
Kevin Durant with the rejection
shot clock violation for KD this is
nasty look at the rank it up
the strength of that play
oh
that's tough Keel gives up his dribble
shot clock is winding down
11 Durant the last line of defense
with the rejection of Turner Big Time
block by Kevin Durant coming from the
weak side Baseline
to help out Joe Harris